ha richard branson whelmed is there
anything he doesn't do a high school
dropout at the age of 16 he started
companies he's seen the world and he has
more adventures than anyone could dream
of in a lifetime he's a creative
personality and a brilliant businessman
as well as being an energetic charitable
man who has built a brand recognizable
around the world and by the way he's
also worth nearly five billion dollars
so how exactly did Branson get to where
he is today let's start at the beginning
of 1950s in Surrey England's Branson was
born the eldest son of Edward and Eve
Branson a lawyer and a flight attendant
there she was a flight attendant Eve
Branson didn't sit idly by on her days
off she built wooden trash cans and
tissue boxes selling them extra money
for the family watching his mother's
success built Branson's admiration for
entrepreneurs and gave him an option for
when school jazzed wasn't working out
she was always supportive of him and was
even known to tell people he would one
day be Prime Minister of England his
mother was also an influence on
Branson's active minds and lifestyle
that had become so much a part of his
international brand today she didn't let
her children watch TV instead pushing
her son and two daughters outside to
entertain themselves and make themselves
useful though clearly brilliant Branson
was not a successful students he had
dyslexia and growing art school it was
difficult for him but dyslexia did not
stop him and now he credits it as a key
part of his formula for success if you
have a learning disability you become a
very good delegator because you know
what your weaknesses are and you know
what your strengths are and you make
sure that you find great people to step
in and deal with your weaknesses he
moved through several schools as a
child's eventually giving up on
institutionalized learning at the age of
sixteen but he did not give up on
achieving when he dropped out of school
he already knew that being an
entrepreneur that was the right life for
him he started out with an idea and with
an ultimate goal far beyond just earning
money from my very first day as an
entrepreneur I
felt the only mission worth pursuing in
business is to make people's lives
better his first venture as a teenage
businessman was publishing a magazine
called students at only 16 years old
with no input or work for anyone but
students Branson was able to secure
eight thousand dollars in advertising
for the magazine's first issue this was
1966 and eight thousand dollars was a
lot more money then so much in fact that
Branson didn't even have to sell the
first issue instead he gave away fifty
thousand copies building the brand's
name and a potentially loyal customer
base for future issues it was the first
demonstration of a brilliant business
minds with an utterly impressive talent
for marketing students it continued in
its original form for three years but in
1969 Branson he felt the urge to make it
even bigger and to take it in a new
direction advertisements for records
were a large part of the magazine's
revenue so Branson took records and the
magazine and put them together
essentially he spotted a gap in the
market for mail-order record sales his
mail-order business when it was
christened with a name that we all know
today and that would be virgin but it
wasn't actually Richard Branson who came
up with that name it was one of his
first employees though they were
successful the name was perfect for the
company as all of the young people
involved in it when you to business
well that name it obviously stuck and
now it's come to represent much more
than just mail-order music though the
mail-order business it was popular it
wasn't making enough money to stay
afloat and Branson when he needed cash
he decided that the best way to do that
was avoid giving the government the
entire share of the taxes that he
actually owed he came up with a scheme
through which he avoided reporting all
of the records that were sold in the UK
falsifying the numbers of those that
were exported it sounded good and it did
bring in cash births well it was
discovered he actually ended up in jail
and having to pay over sixty thousand
dollars in fines this obstacle and a
short time in jail didn't slow him or
his business ambitions down though even
with the tax fraud scandal it was only
less than two years after starting the
main order record business that Branson
was able to take yet another leap in
1971 he opens an actual bricks and
mortar store in order to sell wreck
then it was only a year before he bought
himself a home and was able to build a
recording studio inside us now that he
had a studio the next logical step it
was to start a record label so he looked
around and ended up signing an artist he
thought would be okay but not likely to
have overwhelming success as no one else
would take him on and so what was the
name of this newly created record label
well of course it was Virgin Records the
label had success almost immediately
with its first artist like old Ville
stand on the chance with the album
tubular bells for nearly five years to
put this in perspective the record was
on the charts as long as it took from
Branson to go from selling records by
mail to having his own record label the
success of Oldfield and Branson unto the
upstart virgin label it didn't go
unnoticed far from it
huge names like Sex Pistols The Rolling
Stones Culture Club Janet Jackson and
Genesis they were all later signed onto
the label
[Music]
throughout the 1970s while Branson
wizardess 20s he focused on his
ever-growing music business but by 1984
he was again hitching to try something
new so he took what seems like a pretty
large jump across industries he invested
in a new airline business before
launching the full-fledged airline
service Branson had realized the
potential for doing so when his own
flights to the British Virgin Islands
was cancelled being wealthy he didn't
have to wait around at an airport for
the next flight at the whim of the
airlines he could charter his own plane
so he did it but he didn't keep the
large plane to himself instead he
charged the others who was supposed to
be on his original flight to the British
Virgin Islands a small fee and they all
flew together on the chartered plane
down to the island his creative minds
and business intuition they saw an
opportunity here and Branson well he was
ready to seize it soon after his initial
experimental charter flight to the
British Virgin Islands he called up
Boeing and asked what they had for sale
well they said that they had a Boeing
747 available and Branson bought it and
this was the start of his fleet of
airplanes as he had with the mail-order
record business
Branson saw a need and a way that he
could run a business better than others
who were currently doing so so entry
Richard Branson style they did just that
we just made it that much more special
than the other airlines we were
competing with he says of what he
achieved with Virgin Atlantic Airways
long before it was the norm virgin was
offering such luxuries as individual TV
screens to help people pass the time on
flights now initially Virgin it
operators only out of London's Gatwick
Airport by 1991 it had grown to the
point where it was given permission to
fly out of he throw British Airways well
they were not so pleased by this new
threat to their previously unchallenged
supremacy and they certainly did not sit
idly by while virgin kept calling off
the market share in 1993 virgin it
accused British Airways of a so-called
series of dirty tricks that ranged from
computer hacking to libel following the
accusations British Airways they settled
at forque so that nearly four million
dollars in legal fees and compensation
now you might be wondering well what did
Branson do with the money that he
received in the settlement well he
didn't just stick it all in his own
bank accounts instead he decided to
share it with virgins employees now
though the settlement it was a win for
the company it didn't mean and ransom
were completely successful and had
nothing to worry about on the contrary
in fact Branson was unfortunately forced
to sell his music business in order to
keep his empire going EMI they bought
Virgin Records in 1992 and although it
was a good business decision
it was a tough personal choice for
Branson the music business
it was Branson's baby it was his first
venture and he was the reason everything
else he had built was possible over the
years he's been very open about just how
difficult that sale was for him
I mean you build something from scratch
we had just signed Janet Jackson we had
signed the Rolling Stones when we sold
it and I remember running down Ladbroke
Grove tears streaming down my face with
a check for a billion dollars since the
sale Virgin Airlines has continued to
grow Branson added a cellphone sector to
his business and then a space travel
venture called Virgin Galactic five
hundred people have bought tickets of an
as-yet unscheduled flight into space
with Virgin Galactic over all Richard
Branson owns 200 companies linked to the
Virgin brands but well business is not
its only interest and nor is it
[Music]
Branson he could just sit comfortably in
his island resort home but well he
prefers to explore all corners of the
world and to do so in ways far more
interesting and far more perilous than
in the comfort of a Virgin Atlantic
plane
he's flashier than your average
billionaire with no qualms about risking
his life in the pursuit of adventure
adventure that also serves double duty
as a completely out-of-the-box marketing
strategy he makes no distinction between
his professional and personal endeavors
simply aiming to enjoy life and making a
difference where he can I don't think of
workers work and play as play it's all
living well in 1985 Richard Branson made
international news when he tried to set
a world record for the fastest crossing
of the Atlantic he failed in totally
spectacular fashion as his boat capsized
and he had to be rescued by a British
military helicopter he said of this do
not be embarrassed by your failures
learn from them and start again and well
again in Branson's true form he
absolutely did in 1986 he attempted the
Atlantic crossing again but this time he
succeeded in spectacular fashion he
broke the world record for the crossing
by over two hours but breaking this
record well it wasn't enough for Branson
he wanted more adventure and he also
wanted to keep his name and a virgin his
name in the news he'd done the water
crossing but now he wanted to move on to
air airplanes they were not exciting
enough so he opted to cross the Atlantic
in a hot-air balloon and then I mean
crossing the Atlantic it wasn't enough
so he decided across the Pacific in a
hot-air balloon
now it wasn't all purely for the pursuit
of adventure that he took on these
hot-air balloon challenges he actually
truly enjoyed traveling by hot-air
balloon he said my favorite mode of
transport is hot-air ballooning it's so
graceful to be blown by the winds to go
where the wind takes you now the balloon
Branson took on his first flight it was
a record breaker in and of itself it was
the size of a 21 storey building and it
was built to fly at a speed of over 200
miles per hour it was simply the largest
and the fastest balloon ever constructed
large and fast they didn't make that
balloon immune from danger
the flights path was from the state of
Maine to Ireland and when the balloon
reached Ireland
it didn't detach as it was supposed to
instead Ranson and his crew found
themselves dipping into the freezing
waters of the Atlantic his crew jumped
out of the balloon but Branson was
forced to stay put after the balloon
rapidly lifted twelve thousand feet with
him still in it terrified but able to
remain calm
Branson navigated the balloon back down
towards the water and jumped into the
ocean when he saw he was just a few
dozen feet above its surface and now
let's move on to the Pacific balloon
trip because this wasn't much karma they
ran out of most of their fuel partway
through and they were dependent on the
jet stream to simply push them forward
Branson said I was facing almost certain
death we could have just slumped on the
floor and accepted our fate or try to
fly the balloon into the core of the jet
stream and finds the strongest winds you
can find stay awake for three days and
do everything you can to avoid what on
paper looks like a sad ending Branson's
crew well they chose to stay away you
can do what they could and well they
overcame their challenge they didn't
break the records they hope to but they
did live to tell the tale of their
adventure and that was all he could have
asked for
[Music]
a man like Branson who devotes much of
his life to the pursuit of pleasure and
growing a business might seem to be
pretty full up on time commitments but
for Branson business and success is
about much more than just amassing
wealth it's about helping people I never
started out in business to make money
I wanted to create products that made a
difference in people's lives
the same is true today in my opinion
there's nothing quite like the gift of
giving when you see firsthand the impact
it can have it becomes the best feeling
in the world
Branson has used not only his money but
his brand in his notoriety to influence
world leaders I am Peter Gabriel of the
Virgin Records fans Genesis talked to
Nelson Mandela about their dream of
having a group of world leaders formed
to work on the pressing issues facing
the people of the world well what was
the result of that well that would be
the group of the elders a group of some
of the world's most respected former
leaders including UN officials President
Jimmy Carter and Desmond Tutu Branson he
does provide funding for the group in
its initiatives but it was really his
initial idea and his willingness to
karyn's have those initial conversations
that really made this all possible and
then we come to environmental issues
which shot one of Branson's personal
passions he's committed hundreds of
millions of pounds to fighting global
warming and even hosted a summit at his
private island in 2009 as they might
have the question why does Richard
Branson care about preserving the earth
and its beauty Christ much
well like his creative pets Branson
credits his childhood home and the
amount of time he spent playing outside
to this I was fortunate to have been
brought up in the countryside in a
little cottage I suppose that the first
10 years of my life was spent in the
countryside biking climbing trees and in
touch with nature I suppose that's where
my love of nature started overall he's
worked with dozens of charities in his
life dedicating his time and money to
the causes that he cares most about the
United Nations has even recognized his
efforts giving him their citizen of the
world award in 2007 most recently
Branson has thrown his charitable energy
towards helping the Caribbean islands
rebuild in the wake of Hurricane Ernest
destruction during the fall of 2017 with
this home on Necker Island in the
British Virgin Islands he has a personal
interest in doing so but has gone well
beyond just rebuilding his own luxurious
home he's been
time helping mobilize rescue efforts and
assisting with the distribution of water
and supplies as well as helping people
find shelter clearly Branson is not a
man to stand idly by when there is a
need in providing the Virgen brands and
promoting the courses he cares about
Branson has become a highly recognizable
personality and a frequent guest on news
and other shows but he doesn't always
stick to the serious stuff
he's made cameos in the Bond film Casino
Royale and cemented his place as 90s
icon when he starred on both Baywatch
and Friends he was also featured in the
iconic Apple think different and
alongside such luminaries as John Lennon
Gandhi Einstein and public Casso Richard
Branson he's not your typical uptight
businessman he's a creative luminary who
has impacted all the corners of business
and impacted many parts of the world and
that's what he aims to do each day he
wants to put the things he's passionate
about to work for himself and for the
world a passionate belief in your
business and personal objectives can
make all the difference between success
and failure if you aren't proud of what
you're doing why should anybody else
[Music]
amid everything Branson has also found
time to marry and have children his
first marriage was in the heyday of
virgin records when he went Christin to
Marcy in 1972 that marriage lasted only
seven years and the couple divorced in
1979 Branson had already met his second
wife Joan Templeman by the time he and
Tomasi divorced and as granson admitted
much later to piers morgan he had a
daughter with templeman in 1979 sadly a
child lived for only four days
it wasn't until 10 years and two more
children later that Branson and
Templeman actually tied the knot Richard
Branson he could have continued to
struggle through high school doing
things he hated and that he didn't care
about he could have fought his way to
becoming a lawyer like his dad or
settling into a middle class office job
in London or the surrounding area he
could have stuck it out but he listened
to his instincts and he went with his
heart a dropout he could have fallen to
the bottom and struggled through life
feeling sorry for himself for having a
learning disability but his passion and
his personality along with his mother's
constant encouragement propelled him
forward Richard Branson drew on his
creativity took risks and never shied
from a challenge every time he failed he
brushed himself off and tried again he
gives back to a world that has given him
much and he continues to succeed as a
businessman and as an admired
personality Richard Branson once said
that if you want to stand out from the
crowd
give people a reason not to forget you
Richard Branson wealthy clearly follows
his own advice and this has led him to a
successful and passionate life so I
really hope you enjoyed the video if you
did please do give us a thumbs up below
and do not forget to subscribe to put up
brand new biographies just like this of
modern day people like Richard Branson
or people from history also some things
on the darker science serial killers we
cover the gamut of people we think would
make a good bio graphics video so do you
subscribe brand new videos twice a week
that's Mondays and Thursdays also some
of our all the videos over there on the
right more stuff that you can check out
right now and as always
for watching
[Music]